imagínate que voy a algún tipo de
fábrica y allí estudio sus operaciones y
con esto logró ver como el costo varía
el costo varía con respecto a la
cantidad y para eso le voy a poner q q
lo voy a utilizar como si fuera la
cantidad con respecto a algún periodo de
tiempo no sé un período de tiempo
semanal se me ocurre y bueno si yo
quisiera ver esto de una manera visual
pues déjame hacerlo vamos a trazar aquí
un par de ejes aquí me voy a fijar en mi
eje del costo ok y aquí en mi eje de la
cantidad ok y entonces déjeme poner que
este este de aquí es el eje del costo lo
voy a poner así mientras que este otro
este otro es el eje de la cantidad y
bueno habíamos dicho que la cantidad la
íbamos a denotar con ok y supongamos que
esta función que depende de la cantidad
ok
esta función del costo se ve más o menos
así imagínate que tengo una
va más o menos algo o algo así esta es
mi curva o esta es mi función del costo
con respecto a la cantidad en una semana
ok y bueno seguramente tú vas a decir
que esta tiene toda la lógica del mundo
porque bueno porque empezamos en un
cierto valor para el costo no sé
supongamos mil ok este es mi valor mil y
es que esto tiene toda la lógica del
mundo si yo no produzco nada de todas
maneras voy a gastar no sé ya sea en la
renta del almacén en la renta de la
fábrica o puede ser en la renta de
algunas de las máquinas o inclusive
pagándoles a las personas que estoy
contratando aunque ellos no produzcan
nada ellos tienen un cierto sueldo pero
lo padre de esto es que si nosotros nos
movemos en el eje de la cantidad y no se
supongamos que estamos parados justo
aquí
y vamos a decir que estamos haciendo 100
unidades de esto que está produciendo la
fábrica si te das cuenta aquí está
aumentando el costo y supongamos que
aquí aquí en este punto estamos parados
en el valor de
trescientos mil trescientos es decir que
hacer cien unidades de este producto que
nosotros estamos haciendo nos trae un
costo de mil trescientos mientras que si
no hacemos nada nos trae un costo de
1000 ahora si yo lo que quiero pensar es
en el famoso costo marginal o dicho de
otra manera si me quiero fijar en la
derivada en la derivada de esta función
c con respecto a la cantidad o que por
cierto a esto se le conoce como el costo
marginal o lo podríamos llamar como se
prima de q se prima de q ok la derivada
de ser con respecto a la cantidad la
derivada del costo con respecto a la
cantidad bueno tal vez en una primera
idea a ti se te ocurra decir que esto
esto lo podemos visualizar como la
pendiente de la recta tangente y eso
tiene toda la lógica del mundo si yo me
fijo en este punto no sé y de aquí a
atrás o una recta más o menos así voy a
tratar de que sea lo más tangente
posible y más o menos así
más o menos así ok si yo me fijo en la
pendiente en la pendiente de esta recta
déjame poner así en la pendiente de la
recta tangente bueno pues yo puedo decir
que esto es lo mismo que se prima de tú
ahora nosotros ya sabemos que la
pendiente de una recta es el cambio en
bueno en este caso el cambio en el
cambio con respecto al cambio en la otra
variable que es el cambio en cuba de
lujo pero también lo que nosotros hemos
visto y todo eso gracias a la idea del
cálculo es que si nos fijamos en este
cambio en sem cuando nosotros cambiamos
el cubo de una manera muy pero muy pero
muy pero muy pero muy pequeña es decir
nos tomamos el límite cuando delta de q
cuando el cambio en q tiende a cero
precisamente para tomarnos la recta
tangente entonces podemos decir que esto
es precisamente la derivada de c con
respecto a
y es por eso que nosotros podemos decir
que está pendiente de la recta tangente
es la derivada en cm ok con respecto a q
de bueno este valor que nosotros lo
estamos tomando que es el valor de 100
de 100 unidades que nosotros estamos
produciendo es decir la idea de un
cambio instantáneo la tasa justo en el
margen en el cual el costo está
cambiando respecto a la cantidad y de
ahí viene el nombre de costo marginal es
un margen en el cual el costo está
cambiando con respecto a la cantidad así
que si yo pongo otro poco de este
producto esto nos va a llevar a otra
tasa de cambio y esto lo pueden
visualizar de una manera muy sencilla si
te das cuenta las pendientes de todas
estas rectas tangentes que tienen esta
curva aquí van cambiando es decir no son
constantes justo así es como se modela
la función y bueno si la función se de
hechos fuera una recta en este caso y
solamente
entonces si podríamos decir que el
cambio marginal sería constante porque
al final la recta tangente sel en la
misma función del costo que sería esa
recta pero bueno aquí no es así y puedes
verlo como aquí al aumentar un poco la
producción tiene un costo un poco menor
que aumenta la producción justo aquí y
lo puedes ver así aquí tras una recta
una recta tangente entonces su pendiente
es más grande que la pendiente de esta
de aquí cambiar un poco en lo que voy a
producir aquí tiene un costo menor que
cambiar un poco en lo que voy a producir
aquí y todo esto nos sirve para decir
que esto está de aquí se llama el costo
marginal el costo marginal marginal
la idea de buscar este costo marginal es
ver en qué momento tenemos que dejar de
producir por ejemplo si estos fueran
litros de jugo de naranja y estamos
produciendo litros de jugo de naranja no
sé tal vez aquí en producir un litro de
jugo de naranja me cueste 105 pesos y
luego vendo un 6 pesos y parece ser
factible todavía pero si yo me fijo acá
no sé tal vez imagínate que del mercado
ya no hay más naranjas me acabe todas
las naranjas que hay en el mercado y
tengo que traer naranjas no sé del
extranjero y por lo tanto al traer las
navajas del extranjero el producir un
litro de jugo de naranja me está
apostando no sé 10 pesos pero yo lo
puedo vender solamente a 6 pesos y
entonces ya no es viable seguir
produciendo litros de jugo de naranja es
justo por eso que me sirve el costo
marginal para ver en qué punto es bueno
dejar de producir y bueno es por eso que
es tan importante esto para la economía
si nosotros tenemos a la función del
costo como cambia con respecto a la
cantidad entonces cuando nosotros
vamos derivamos esta función se con
respecto a la cantidad estamos hablando
del costo marginal o también lo podemos
ver como la tasa de cambio del costo
cuando nosotros cambiamos en producir
una unidad esto se llama el costo
marginal y además no sólo eso también
podemos hablarnos de ingresos marginales
de insi tenemos la función de ingresos
con respecto a la cantidad o de
beneficio marginal que es lo mismo que
un ingreso marginal si nosotros sabemos
la otra función la función de ingreso o
de beneficio con respecto a la cantidad
y bueno es por eso que nosotros podemos
hablar ya de costo de costo marginal que
realmente nos referimos en la primera
derivada del costo con respecto a la
cantidad y de ingreso y beneficio
marginal